foreign
at first glance walks is an
extraordinarily successful media
organization on YouTube alone they have
11 million subscribers and over 3
billion views and in the last 30 days
itself they've gained over 20 million
views and over a hundred thousand
subscribers given the high quality
journalism and the documentaries that
come out of box it's not surprising that
they're so successful but what may be
surprising is that there is a large
community that can't stand box they
believe that box Q's perspectives and
that much of their content centers
around it garnering attention as opposed
to truly informing it's not just some
viewers that are put off by their
content either many journalists are as
well just one Google search will bring
up dozens of opinion pieces trashing on
box but much of this you can just write
off as natural criticism whenever an
organization gets relatively large it's
gonna attract to detractors regardless
of what they do but something that you
can't right off as simply is The Exodus
at Vox Johnny Harris is likely the most
notable example but he's by no means the
only one another Vox journalist turned
YouTuber is Cleo Abram and it's not just
journalists who are leaving box either
this Exodus actually goes all the way to
the top in just the last few years two
out of the three Vox Founders left the
company and it's not like these guys
completely quit the journalism or the
media industry altogether they just quit
box Matthew Iglesias for example left so
that he could become a writer at a paid
newsletter called sub stack similarly as
recline and left Vox to become a notable
journalist at the New York Times yet
another executive who ditched Vox is
Lauren Williams while she wasn't a
co-founder she did serve as
editor-in-chief and Senior vice
president to make things worse all three
of these departures happened in the same
month November of 2020. there is also a
good chance that box is dealing with
some Financial challenges throughout
this recession given that they laid off
39 people last year so what happened at
tavox
taking a look back at Ezra Klein wasn't
always looking to ditch walks in fact
not too long ago he was looking to ditch
The Washington Post Ezra was the head of
a public policy blogger where he
regularly analyzed and discussed
upcoming legislation and the political
landscape while this was a pretty safe
position to be in Ezra felt the need to
address a shortfall within the market he
felt that the traditional media Outlets
weren't providing in-depth explanatory
journalism his first instinct was to
pitch the idea to upper management but
after they rejected his idea it didn't
take him long to leave it and he took
several Washington Post employees with
them including one of vox's other
co-founders Melissa Bell together they
hired a team of 20 people each of whom
were an expert in a given topic area and
shortly after they launched a box on
April 6 2014 with the goal of making the
news exciting again their initial
content focused on explaining various
facets of the Affordable Care Act or
Obamacare they also spend time exploring
economic issues like the massive public
debt these articles and videos performed
quite well especially for our brand new
media organization but it would take Vox
a few months to really trigger the
YouTube algorithm which brings us to
their first viral hit three big reasons
war is going away they followed this up
with yet another viral hit just a few
weeks later titled weed is not more
dangerous than alcohol pretty quickly
walk started to build a name for
themselves as the edgy media outlet that
wasn't afraid to make their positions
clear I mean they were literally
claiming that the US debt wasn't a big
deal and that weed should not be
ostracized they even had videos
comparing Bitcoin to the internet and
debunking Shark Week while many of these
were great one-off videos Lux was yet to
find a Core Series that people would
tune in for but this would change on
July 23 2014 when walks posted a video
called what may North Korea is so
bizarre Weiss had already popular
authorized The elusive nature of North
Korea across YouTube so when Vox posted
a video about North Korea and instantly
went viral and since then North
korea-based content has become a staple
on the channel garnering tens of
millions of views it looks like this is
one of the things that Johnny Harris
took with them from box as he has his
own multi-million View North Korea video
speaking of Johnny Harris he was an
early employee at Vox having joined in
2014 as a senior video producer aside
from producing videos about North Korea
Johnny worked on producing map-based
videos eventually Dania would emerge The
elusive aspect of North Korea with the
geographical aspect of maps and the
combination of these two sides would
lead to the creation of one of vox's
most popular docu-series of all time
borders which brings us into the Glory
Days of Vox
foreign
in the late 2010s logs was killing it if
you go to their Channel and sort by most
popular you'll see that virtually all of
their most popular videos were posted
during this time period not only did
they have deep thought-provoking content
about various Hot Topics but they
delivered said content in an exceptional
way this is something that hasn't
changed that box to this day the quality
of their animations infographics and
editing is Top Notch for YouTube and
honestly it's better than even most
traditional media Outlets you could say
that Vox had achieved their goal of
making informative videos not just
watchable or informative but full-on
entertaining with every video there was
a beginning middle and end with the main
characters failures and successes each
video was a story a journey through a
specific topic or historical event
something that made Vox even more
popular was the downfall of cable TV
more and more people were switching
completely to streaming platforms like
Netflix clicks and Hulu but while these
platforms had super exciting shows and
along from documentaries something that
they lagged was news-based content and
all of this combined that led to the
extraordinary rise of what we all know
as Vlogs today but wait a minute where's
the bad stuff if Fox was producing such
great content why do a large portion of
viewers and the journalists hate walks
and why are leading hosts and even
Founders leaving the company well the
answer is that like Vox I've only been
telling one side of the story throughout
this entire Journey walks had another
side that was not nearly as respected
and I think the best way to explain this
other side is as the BuzzFeed side if
you're not familiar with the BuzzFeed it
there are another popular media company
that gained much of their Fame during
the same time period as Vox instead of
focusing on use based content though
BuzzFeed focused on entertainment and
experiences and they were Infamous for
their click bait BS articles here's a
few just to get give you an idea I
cannot believe the haircut at crimes
just gave her an Elon musk's baby 10
signs that your cat is a wizard which
ousted Arab Spring ruler are you given
that the Vox was in a much more serious
informative Niche you would think that
there would be above such articles but
they weren't who is Salonga and why is
she attacking it Jay-Z Jay-Z called
lacrosse soft the research literature
disagrees the time when hip-hop's top
drag queen met RuPaul in many of these
cases the writers knew that the Articles
were ridiculous but they posted them
anyway because they also knew that they
could leverage these celebrities and
their drama while these articles may
have gotten clicks they took away from
vox's credibility as the informative and
reputable digital media organization in
the grand scheme of things though this
was by far their smallest offense the
real critique of Vox is that they tell
one-sided stories
foreign
political but that's impossible to
achieve it when Fox themselves is so
political basically every video they
post has an underlying liberal agenda
and that this dates back to their very
first videos how Obamacare will change
health insurance forever competent women
are getting bypassed by overconfident
men weed is not more dangerous than
alcohol I'm not suggesting that any of
these stances are right or wrong but
simply that they only cover one side of
the story this doesn't just stop at the
headlines or thumbnails either basically
every word and every sentence in the
video is carefully concocted to make you
think a certain way when in reality real
journalism should focus on providing an
objective view of all perspectives I
mean this is one of the biggest problems
with traditional media as well you've
got your liberal Outlets like CNN the
New York Times and NBC and you've got
your conservative Outlets like Fox the
New York Post and Newsmax given that one
of vox's goals was to make up for the
shortfalls of Legacy Media you would
think that they would have spent a lot
of effort in gathering and conveying
diverse viewpoints but instead it it
seems like Volks has simply become a
traditional media Outlet that's good at
social media and the internet but
despite the new medium fox says all of
the same issues as traditional media and
it's not just liberal viewpoints that
they support either they even go as far
as defending people from the left one of
the best examples of this is with a
journalist named Sarah Zion in 2019
Sarah made the following remarks on
Twitter oh man it's kind of sick how
much joy I get out of being cool to old
white men white people marking up the
internet with their opinions like the
dogs pissing on fire hydrants and
hashtag cancel white people Vox
published not one but three separate
articles defending Cyril they even went
as far as categorizing Sarah's comments
as the expressive way anti-racists and
minorities talk about white people and
they categorize the arguments from the
other side as a major bullying tactic of
the alt-right I don't think anything
else needs to be said about this
situation over the years these types of
situations have simply increased in
popularity leading to much of the
distaste surrounding a box it's
incredibly ironic that box is a Latin
for voice yet they are actively involved
in the censorship and the platforming of
people and the groups they dislike if I
see there's a source then I always back
check the information not a source that
I'd like to link to other people as
being reliable not to say everything is
wrong just more likely to be twisted in
some way their gimmick is claiming to be
objective explainers of the news but in
fact they give it a strong leftward Spin
and that this seems to be the primary
issue with the Box
foreign
started off as an ambitious startup that
was looking to achieve something that
traditional media couldn't this meant
conveying seemingly boring topics enough
on it and intuitive manner while
maintaining objectivity and Clarity but
instead it seems that Vox has fallen
into the same trap as traditional media
they ended up choosing one-sided and
going deeper and deeper at this point
there is so far to one-sided that they
believe that Center Summit is actually
the media's biggest bias and I think
this one Reddit comment described the
situation the best it's pseudo news yes
it conveys facts and explains current
events but it does so with bias and they
often cherry pick evidence good
entertainment but not something you
should watch if you're genuinely trying
to inform yourself on topic and that's
what happened to Vox I do gotta say
though despite their shortfalls their
production quality is still insane so
respect there anyway are you guys fans
of walks comment that down below also
drop a like if you would like to see a
truly objective news organization and of
course consider checking out our Discord
Community to just put everybody ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered until then
I'm Ari and I'll see you guys on the
next one